Luke Tom and Nathan here with the
outdoor boys YouTube channel and today
we're gonna show you our favorite
campfire trees cooking and eating food
by the campfires one of my favorite
things to do with the family when
camping and it's just a great way to
spend time and get kids outdoors so I'm
gonna show you some of my favorite
campfire treats now these are gonna be
easy recipes that anyone can do the kids
can help you with and they don't require
a lot of specialty gear or specialty
ingredients so without further ado let
me show you my favorite campfire tree
number one on my list of favorite
campfire treats is a roasted strawberry
covered in marshmallow fluff oh yeah
it's as good as it sounds
roasting strawberries is super easy just
get a jar of marshmallow fluff a thing
of fresh strawberries cut the top offs
and stick them on a sharp stick just
like you would roasting marshmallows
then dunk the strawberries into the jar
of marshmallow fluff and the marshmallow
fluff doesn't like to stick to the
strawberries too much so use your finger
or if you're more into sanitation use a
knife to just kind of smear it around a
little bit and there you go it takes
slightly more time to roast a strawberry
than it does in normal marshmallows so
it's pretty quick and it's pretty easy
and in our house we like our
marshmallows a little bit crispier so
that's how I'm cooking it here for my
wife what do you think
I love it we good
is really really good chocolate
strawberry number two on my list is
roasted starburst
sounds weird but trust me it's it's
great and people who love it
love it okay the classic okay I'm not
the only person who does this I swear
this is actually a thing but just slide
these starbursts a couple out of time on
the end of a stick and there you go easy
as that just melt them over a fire
they'll start to bubble a little bit at
the edges and start to get a little bit
drippy and just kind of twirl the stick
to keep it from dripping off and you're
good to go just make sure it cools down
a little bit before you pop it in your
mouth because it is hot it's kind of
like eating hot out of the oven salt
water taffy or something like it's no
big change in the flavor but it's just
warm and gooey and it's fun and it's so
easy and - you gotta try it
bring a bag of starbursts the next time
you build a campfire you like it yeah
well number three on my list is my
favorite breakfast campfire treat
cinnamon rolls on a stick for this all
you're gonna need is a can of those
refrigerated ready to make cinnamon
rolls just get come in the little can
you can buy them in three packs or eight
packs or twelve packs and then just take
one of the cinnamon rolls and unwrap it
so it's a long piece of dough and take
that piece of dough and start twisting
it as tightly as you can around the end
of a stick as the dough expands and
cooks it'll get kind of saggy or and
looser so you kind of want to start off
relatively tight on the stick and then
skewer it on the end to keep it pinned
on to the end and there you go
that's what it should look like and you
want it nice and thin a nice thin layer
so it'll cook quicker now hold your hand
over the fire and find a spot where you
can hold your hand for the count of
three seconds that's about 350 degrees
that's where you
to rest your stick at and you're gonna
sit it there for about 10 to 15 minutes
you know turn it occasionally let it
brown on all sides and smear a little
frosting on it and you're good to go and
that is how you make cinnamon rolls on a
stick
waking up in the morning to a fresh hot
cinnamon roll that's luxury camping my
friend
oh good well number four on my list is a
campfire comfort food that could
arguably be called healthy baked apple
there are so many different ways you
could do this you can use this little
coring device that I got or you can just
cut it up with a knife but basically get
your apple slices put a little brown
sugar on them and be generous with the
brown sugar put a little dab of butter
on there right there in the middle of it
add some raisins and then fold the thing
up as best you can into a little ball of
tinfoil and it doesn't have to go back
exactly you could just make a pile of
apple slices if you wanted to it doesn't
have to go back into the form of a an
apple but in rate you got this little
ball of tinfoil you don't want to
compress the tinfoil too tightly and
then just put it in some hot coals and
turn it occasionally and it'll be in
there for about Oh 10 minutes and once
it starts to steam starts to come out of
the tinfoil then you know it's done and
pop that sucker up and just the the
smell is so good this tastes really good
with a little granola mixed in well
instant oatmeal it is fabulous stuff and
it's not too bad for you a little bit of
sugar number five on my list maple syrup
kettle corn one of my favorite for
kettle corn you want to get the coals
just right so have a really healthy
roaring bed of coals and put your cast
iron pot or any type of pot right there
in the coals and get it hot you want it
hot enough that the oil will smoke but
you don't want it to catch on fire so
once you've got a nice level bed of
holls it's the right temperature just
barely cover the bottom in oil like a
canola oil and then once the oil is hot
throw in a couple popcorn seeds just to
test to see if it works well they should
pop within about 30 seconds of a minute
of being put in the oil or sooner if
that's the case then add your popcorn
seeds and start and stir them up really
good once they've been in there and
they're just about to start popping add
about a quarter of a cup half a cup of
maple syrup ample amount of white sugar
put it back on the fire and let it start
popping in and stoke those coals get it
hot and you'll start to hear it popping
make sure you keep the lid on when the
popcorn first stops popping otherwise
it'll splatter hot oil into the fire and
catch things on fire then just make sure
you stir it once it's really gets going
and so that you don't burn the stuff on
the bottom oh it's so sticky this is one
of the trickiest recipes on my list but
it's well worth the effort getting the
oil temperature just right to the
kernels popped when they should and
adding the sugar at the right time so it
doesn't burn is really key but the nice
thing about kettle corn is its kettle
corn you burn a few batches so I dump it
out start all over again doesn't take
that much time to try again number six
on my list is s'mores but not just any
old s'mores Nutella and bisque off
cookie spread s'mores oh yeah
making this more with a spread instead
of a Hershey bar is so much easier to
make and so much easier that you will
never go back
there's a big slug in the fire that's
how you do a proper marshmallow right
there folks there are so many different
types of spreads you can use there's the
Nutella the bisque off cookie spread
there's white chocolate peanut butter
Reese's Pieces peanut butter you name it
you can put it on a cracker and make us
more with it and it's probably gonna be
pretty awesome so get out there and
experiment have some real fun with this
[Music]
this is good stuff here this is how you
make us more number seven on my list is
campfire cheer oohs these little balls
enjoy you're gonna rock your world okay
get those refrigerated instant dinner
rolls the little tubes the small ones
pop that open and start cutting them in
half you want little small chunks slip
them on the end of your marshmallow
stick and then you're gonna roast them
just like the cinnamon rolls you want to
find a spot above the fire that's 350
degrees so hold your hand over the fire
and if you can comfortably hold it for
three seconds that's about 350 and
that's where you want your stick to rest
turn it every once in a while and while
you're waiting prepare the baggie full
of sugar put some white sugar and some
ground cinnamon in a bag mix it up about
equal parts cinnamon and sugar and then
once the little rolls are cooked rub
them in butter until the butter all
melts and gets all nice and gooey then
pop them into the bag and toss them
around and get them all coated and
cinnamon and sugar and there you go that
is how you make campfire heroes pretty
simple but very tasty
okay these campfire heroes don't
actually taste much like tier
other than they have cinnamon and sugar
on him but they really are good there
they're more like donut holes or just
kind of I got dry cinnamon roll but
they're really easy to make and they're
fun and they're a great little breakfast
treat as well number eight on my list is
a blast from my childhood campfire
Donuts well that's good for donut holes
you're gonna need a bed of hot coals so
get a flat spot situated in your fire
put your pot whether it's a cast-iron
pot or a normal cooking pot in the coals
and then add a couple inches of canola
oil or peanut oil
don't let it get hot enough where it
starts smoking always be careful with
hot oil a little splash in cause the
only tool you're gonna need is a long
thin stick once you've got your stick
ready start punching holes in the middle
of the dinner rolls and stretch them out
a little bit wider than you'd think is
necessary because the holes will close
up once they start cooking once you've
got a big thing of rolls going take some
powdered sugar
dump it into a bag and then take a
little test bit of dough and put it in
the oil to check the temperature it
should figure ously but not blackened
too quickly if the temperatures right
start chucking in your donuts once they
start to brown on one side use your
little stick to flip them over and once
things are going well you can use the
stick to to pull them out and they cook
very quickly probably in about a minute
and a half two minutes all the donuts
are completely done pull them out and
shake off the oil and then dump them in
the bag with the powdered sugar toss
them around a little bit shake off the
excess powder sugar and there you go
well my fondest childhood camping
memories is winter camping in Alaska it
was negative five I get out of my snow
cave in the morning I'm frozen solid and
somebody hands me a warm campfire donut
and it was the best-tasting thing ever
still is hmm.well number nine on my list
is one of the most decadent and
luxurious of all of the campfire treats
on this list the campfire banana split
this recipe is really hard to mess up
you just take a banana peel on and
you've got it like a fish open the thing
up make some space and put whatever
sweet things you want to put in there
we've got these little Reese's Pieces
chips marshmallows you do chocolate
chips fudge peanuts you know whatever
little sugar throw whatever sounds good
to you on there wrap it up loosely and
some tinfoil try not to compress the
ball too much find a spot in the coals
it isn't too hot and then just turn it
and rotate it every minute or two for
about eight minutes ten minutes maximum
you open it up and it's kind of this hot
sweet mess and open up one of these
packages of pudding and put a pudding
Cup on there and then add some sprinkles
just to make it pretty there you go oh
that's good the campfire banana split
doesn't win any points for presentation
it kind of looks like a hot mess but it
is one of the best tasting on this
entire list and it tastes like just the
ultimate fresh hot banana cream pie it's
not too sweet
it's not like a s'more where you eat one
you're kind of like I'm done you know
that's too much sugar for me yeah it's
just really good mmm number 10 on my
list is baked candied sweet it is really
difficult to screw this recipe up it is
a very very simple recipe just split a
small yam down lengthwise and then put
some butter on there butter it like a
roll be be generous with the butter and
then you're gonna add some brown sugar
and once again be generous with it a lot
of its gonna leak out add some cinnamon
and that a handful of little mini
marshmallows and don't be shy I mean a
lot of this stuff is going to leave
yeah and not get used so use a little
bit more than you think would be
necessary
wrap it up loosely in tin foil put it on
the coals and leave it on the fire for
about 12 to 15 minutes you can overkill
it and usually nothing nothing goes
wrong when you can stab it with a knife
and it just goes slides through very
easily it's cooked all the way and it is
just gooey and good very very nice big
sweet yam it's probably one of those few
snacks it has some nutritional value
might even call it a side dish but it's
great comfort food easy to make tastes
great well hopefully you liked that
video and you learn something new if
you'd like to see more great videos from
the outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and stay tuned because
we're going to be going to Alaska next
week so there's going to be some awesome
videos coming really soon thanks for
watching